et de vous passer le flambeau
vous êtes appelés à diriger l'action du
gouvernement c'est un honneur immense
c'est une charge assez lourde
mais connaissant votre intelligence
votre connaissance fine du pays
votre sincère attachement à l'état
connaissant votre sens politique comme
votre rigueur intellectuelle
je n'ai aucun doute sur le fait que vous
saurez face à des décisions qui sont
parfois difficiles prendre les bonnes
décisions et je voudrais vous dire que
je vous souhaite à la fois beaucoup de
au jeu pas beaucoup pas véritablement
besoin de vous souhaiter du courage
d'abord parce que je sais que vous en
avez et ensuite parce que si vous n'en
aviez pas vous ne seriez pas là mais je
vous souhaite très sincèrement beaucoup
de réussite
beaucoup de succès du succès pour vous
bien entendu mais surtout du succès pour
notre pays qui sort n'est pas encore
complètement sortis d'une crise
sanitaire dont vous savez tous les
aspects tous les dangers mais aussi
toutes les mesures qui ont été prises
pour lutter contre ces effets et notre
pays qui a traversé cette crise
sanitaire qui a traversé d'autres crises
a besoin d'un esprit ouvert et d'une
main ferme
mais je pense que vous avez cet esprit
ouvert et cette main ferme
permettez moi monsieur le premier
ministre
deux homosexuels hôtel de matignon de
formuler quelques remerciements
remerciements d'abord à l'attention du
président de la république qui depuis
plus de trois ans m'a fait confiance et
avec qui j'ai eu la très grande chance
de pouvoir travailler dans des
conditions de confiance de fluidité de
qui qui resteront toute ma vie comme
trois années assez exceptionnelle et
d'une incroyable densité d'une
incroyable richesse
je voudrais également remercier
l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
la passation de pouvoir à laquelle nous
procédons a été rapide et ne m'a pas
être pas permis de dire à chacun d'entre
eux l'estiment la reconnaissance
l'affection que leur portée nous avons
avec eux traversé des moments parfois
difficiles parfois heureux et j'ai
vraiment pour eux au moment où je
m'exprime un grand sentiment de
reconnaissance je veux leur dire s'il ne
regarder s'il m'entendre je voudrais
également remercier et vous vous en
doutez l'ensemble des parlementaires
au premier rang d'entre eux évidemment
les parlementaires de la majorité qui
monte accompagné m'ont soutenu une n'ont
jamais manqué ils étaient ils seront
exigeants ils étaient ils seront
déterminés à tenir les engagements qui
ont été pris en 2017 par le président de
la république je veux très sincèrement
les remercier et leur dire que aussi
longtemps qu'il me sera possible je les
aiderai je voudrais aussi profiter de
l'occasion qui m'est faite pour
remercier les autres parlementaires ceux
qui ne sont pas dans la majorité ceux
qui sont dans l'opposition une bonne
démocratie impose une bonne opposition
et l'opposition est nécessaire dans une
démocratie
elle est également exigeante également
déterminé et je veux remercier les
présidents groupe et au delà l'ensemble
des parlementaires de l'opposition qui
en étant exigeant et critique nous ont
probablement permis d'être meilleur je
voudrais remercier aussi tous les
interlocuteurs avec lesquels j'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir travailler lettre à
matignon ce n'est pas simplement dirigé
l'action du gouvernement c'est aussi
avoir la chance de pouvoir faire des
rencontres des rencontres avec des
femmes et des hommes qui sont dans des
situations de pouvoir ou d' influence
mais aussi avec des femmes et des hommes
qui croient en leur pays qui essaie de
faire avancer leurs dossiers leurs
convictions leurs idées qui viennent à
vous parfois impressionnés par le poste
de premier ministre mais au fond souvent
désireux de parler avec l'homme où la
femme qu'ils occupent et de telles
rencontres ces belles rencontres j'en ai
lu beaucoup pendant ces trois ans et
vous en aurez à ne pas douter pendant
les mois et les années qui viennent
ils sont parfois élus maires des deux
communes de france comme vous l'êtes
comme je vais leur devenir
ils sont parfois responsables syndicaux
et ils sont parfois simple si j'ose dire
citoyen mais citoyens à part entière
défendant leur idée voulant partager des
choses avec vous et au moment où je vous
parle mille visages me viennent à
l'esprit un peu partout en france
je voudrais saluer particulièrement les
forces politiques de nouvelle-calédonie
car vous verrez monsieur le premier
ministre à matignon on parle beaucoup de
nouvelle calédonie et le processus
extraordinaire extraordinaire qui a été
engagé en nouvelle calédonie bien avant
ce gouvernement est poursuivi par
beaucoup de premier ministre depuis
michel rocard est un un processus
fascinant difficile complexe incertain
encore mais il faut rendre hommage à nos
concitoyens du pacifique qui oeuvre pour
essayer de trouver la bonne solution
les bonnes solutions pour pour cette île
d' incroyablement attachante
je voudrais et vous le comprendrez
aisément monsieur le premier ministre
remercier très sincèrement également
tous ceux qui m'ont accompagné ici à
matignon être premier ministre sait
diriger l'action d'un gouvernement c'est
servir l'état
c'est aussi être accompagné par des
équipes par un cabinet remarquablement
dirigées par des femmes et des hommes
qui parfois ont été choisis par d'autres
que moi parce que je ne les connaissais
pas tous en arrivant
mais qui ont démontré chaque jour à
chaque instant et parfois dans des
conditions difficiles
un sens de l'état un sens du service
public
un attachement à notre pays à la france
qui me donne une confiance absolue
absolue dans notre capacité à relever
les plus grands défis à tout cela les
membres de mon cabinet les membres de
l'administration qui font vivre
matignon a tous les agents de l'état qui
croient sincèrement à ce que c'est que
le sens de l'état et à tous nos
concitoyens qui ont fermement ancré en
eux la conviction que le civisme
ce n'est pas la sphère des autres et
c'est le ciment des grandes nations
je veux dire ah merci très sincère très
sincère et toute ma reconnaissance
il vous appartiendra à monsieur le
premier ministre désormais de continuer
à servir la france ou la servait depuis
bien longtemps
c'est une belle responsabilité
alors je suis un peu ému en vous disant
cela mais soyez bon
et comme on dit chez moi bon vent
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon
bon ça suffit maintenant
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le premier ministre
cher edouard les trois années que vous
avez passé ici là matignon a dirigé
l'action gouvernementale resteront sans
nul doute marqué dans l'histoire de
notre pays
vous me permettrez de commencer par la
fin puisque vous avez été le chef du
gouvernement qui a dû affronter la plus
grave crise sanitaire qui est affecté
notre pays bien sûr l'europe le monde
depuis de très nombreuses décennies
il se trouve aussi monsieur le premier
ministre que c'est dans ces
circonstances que vous avez bien voulu
faire appel à moi pour vous seconder
dans cet exercice et notamment dans la
phase dite de déconfinement j'ai donc eu
l'honneur de travailler de près sur
votre autorité quotidiennement sous
celle du président de la république et
je voudrais tout simplement ici
publiquement témoigné de l'engagement
qui a été le vôtre du souci constant
constant de protéger nos concitoyens
d'expliquer la situation
les dispositions que celles ci commet
des
vous l'avez fait toujours avec la clarté
et la pédagogie qui ont caractérisé
chacune de vos interventions
bien avant la survenue de cette crise
sanitaire
dois-je rappeler monsieur le premier
ministre
qu'à la fin de l'année dernière au début
de l'actuelle la france notre pays
présentait l'un des taux de croissance
les plus élevés d'europe que le chômage
toujours trop élevé bien sûr et est à
son niveau le plus bas depuis dix ans
que le niveau des investissements était
le plus élevé depuis dix ans que la
progression du pouvoir d'achat était la
plus forte que vous avez engagé une
baisse de la fiscalité
parmi les plus vigoureuses depuis dix
ans tout ceci
mesdames et messieurs ce sont des faits
on pourrait y ajouter les réformes
structurelles que vous avez conduite et
pour revenir à la période la plus
récente aux mesures que votre
gouvernement a adopté les plus
vigoureuses d'europe pour éviter que
notre économie ne s'effondre avec
rappelons le aussi une attention
constante aux plus faibles et aux plus
démunis tout ça
les françaises et les français l'ont vu
ils ont appris à vous connaître
je pense même comme moi qu'ils ont pu
identifier un style edouard philippe
un style edouard philippe comme un
article de de mode mais oui vous avez
tout à leur parler de courage
c'est une vertu essentielle non
seulement politiques mais surtout dans
la direction des affaires de l'état
la clairvoyance la hauteur de vue en
employant ce terme je pense que chacun
se reconnaîtra dans mes propos et enfin
pour ne pas donner un catalogue trop
long ce premier n'aimeriez pas ça
l'élégance d'élégance donc tous les sens
de ce terme
je mesure cher edouard l'émotion qui est
la vôtre dans la solennité de cet
instant comme chacun du reste imagine la
mienne
au moment où je prends ces lourdes
fonctions
nous en avons souvent parlé ensemble
je sais que quelque chose vient atténuer
cette situation le fait que vous allez
retrouver pleinement vos belles
fonctions de maire votre belle ville du
havre et tous ses habitants qui
récemment encore vous ont témoigné leur
affection et leur attachement
dans un contexte que nous pourrions
qualifié de difficile
un maire du sud un peu plus loin du
monde rural vient donc remplacer un mer
du nord de la loire d'une grande ville
industrielle maritime ainsi et la france
dans sa diversité mais que nous devons
plus que jamais à unifier réconcilier
chacune et chacun
en ce qui nous concerne on vous l'avait
fait nos styles aussi assurément sont
différents mais je voudrais mesdames et
messieurs nous permettent de revendiquer
avec edouard philippe
une communauté de valeurs ses valeurs
démocratiques et républicaines au
premier rang desquels sans doute la
conception suivant laquelle le service
de l'intérêt général et de l'état
doivent prévaloir sur toute autre
considération
aujourd'hui ainsi que l'a décidé le
président de la république une nouvelle
étape du quinquennat s'ouvre elle est
très largement dictée
monsieur le premier ministre par un
contexte lui-même nouveau un contexte
pesant un contexte difficile la crise
sanitaire
vous l'avez dit n'est malheureusement
pas terminée les regards que nous
pouvons porter à cet égard sur les pays
qui nous entourent le démontre la crise
économique et sociale elle est déjà là
les priorités devront donc évoluer les
méthodes devront donc être adaptées et
il nous faudra plus que jamais réunir la
nation pour lutter contre cette crise
qui s'installe et surtout dans la
continuité des réformes de forme que
vous avez entreprises pour faire en
sorte que nous en sortions plus fort et
plus solidaire merci beaucoup
mon cher edouard certes pour vos propos
surtout pour votre action au service de
nos concitoyens
nul ne doute ici que vos immense talent
vont durablement rester au service de la
france
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez vu en direct cette passation
de pouvoirs et douars philippe qui passe
le flambeau à jean castex dans un
discours assez ému et longuement
applaudi également à ses côtés
castex qui était qui est dorénavant
nouveau premier ministre lui a adressé
un discours élogieux on retrouve tout de
suite notre reporter kirill kotick off
devant matignon qui risque aussi comme
vous êtes devant matignon
que faut-il retenir de cette prestation
[Applaudissements]
et bien beaucoup de solennité et
d'émotion on vous l'avait dit edouard
philippe était particulièrement ému lors
de son discours pouvait entendre
derrière moi les gens qui applaudissent
avec ce portail de l'hôtel de matignon
qui est en train de s'ouvrir
edouard philippe qui était très ému lors
de son discours on a pu entendre même
parfois quelques larmes dans sa voie il
a remercié ses équipes qui l'ont
accompagné durant trois ans à matignon
cela faisait longtemps qu'un premier
ministre n'était pas rester aussi
longtemps en poste il faut le savoir
servez la france soyez bon c'est ce cas
c'est ce qu'a dit edouard philippe à son
successeur jean castex et puis jean
castex a enchaîné son discours avec son
accent quelque peu chantant du sud-ouest
de la france puisqu'il est maire d'une
petite commune des pyrénées orientales
il n'a pas manqué d'éloges envers
edouard philippe il a évoqué la hausse
du pouvoir d'achat la baisse du chômage
la gestion d'une crise sanitaire sans
précédent sous le mandat d'edouard
philippe il a aussi parlé d'un style
edouard philippe il est vrai que le
désormais ex premier ministre a beaucoup
fait parler d'eux par son humour qui ne
l'a pas qu'il n'a pas
oublié de mettre en oeuvre durant son
mandat et puis la cote de popularité il
faut le rappeler aussi est en hausse 1
d'edouard philippe qui a été réélu
récemment au havre il va maintenant
retourner dans son fief de normandie il
avait dit au début de son mandat qu'il
serait difficile pour lui de se faire un
nom avec deux prénoms avec une touche
d'humour dont tout le monde se souvient
et puis c'est vrai que cet instant était
finalement solennelle puisque jean
castex a fait savoir que c'était amer du
sud rural qui venait remplacer à mer du
nord portuaires que c'était aussi ça la
france la france de la diversité la
france de la passation et de
l'alternance des points de vue et que la
crise sanitaire n'étant pas terminée la
crise économique et sociale étant
toujours là il fallait redoubler
d'efforts et de beaucoup de méthodes
adaptées et de défis à relever pour
qu'un nouveau mandat de ce nouveau
premier ministre puisse se dérouler dans
de bonnes conditions voilà cette
passation de pouvoir est désormais
terminée après de longues heures
d'attentes devant l'hôtel matignon c'est
jean castex qui prend la place d'edouard
philippe aujourd'hui à la tête de
matinée merci kirill kotick offre pour
toutes ces précisions et justement pour
débriefer de cette passation de pouvoir
nous sommes en direct avec jean bizet
sénateur et l'air de la manche président
de la commission des affaires
européennes du sénat
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors cette
passation de pouvoir on l'a vu ça a été
un moment solennel beaucoup d'émotion et
d'applaudissements
peut-être on a un problème technique
jean jean bizet ce que vous vous
m'entendez je disais cette passation de
pouvoir ça a été un moment solennel il
ya eu beaucoup d'émotions
d'applaudissements également comment
est-ce que vous réagissez cette
passation de pouvoir écoutez moi je
voudrais saluer l'action d'edouard
philippe pendant tout fait moi toutes
ces semaines à matignon c'est un homme
qui a montré une grande humilité une
grande capacité d'écouté et une grande
attention aux français dans des moments
difficiles tel que nous l'avons vécu au
travers du la pandémie du convive 19
états membres délire on le voit les
sondages l'ont le portent de plus en
plus je pense
vertement je regrette son départ je
regrette son départ nous nous sommes
entretenus dans les couloirs du sénat
mardi
et je lui ai fait part de mon souhait
qu'il reste et m'a simplement adressé un
clin d'oeil donc j'avais compris que
c'était pas du tout évident je tiens on
a vu cette passation de pouvoirs assez
ou vendent beaucoup d'émotion de la part
d' edouard philippe de l'humour
également deux hommes différents
est-ce que c'est deux styles et deux
manières de gouverner selon vous écouter
on va voir ce que va pouvoir réaliser
mathieu castex j'ai fait tard aux
fonctionnaires peu connu personnellement
je ne le connais pas mais jamais je n'ai
entendu de mal le concernant et quand on
regarde faire la bibliographie ni on est
quand même frappé que même si tu étais
un haut fonctionnaire depuis très
longtemps dans une petite commune prades
et bien il ya eu lui aussi l'humilité de
s'investir au plus proche de nos
concitoyens et je le fais par des
collègues presqu'île jeu je me suis
empressé de savoir qu'il était
toutes sensibilités confondues tout le
monde en inventer si je peux dire la
mairie c'est quelqu'un qui ressemble un
peu à mon sens à edouard philippe
c'est quelqu'un encore une fois frappé
d'humilité et d' écoute et je crois que
dans une société dans une france très
fracturée à vif avec l'épisode des gilet
jaune avec je dirais les les
les violences qui malheureusement est
mike trop nos nos villes et nos
banlieues je pense que nous avons besoin
de cette fois de ses force tranquille
qui connaissait personnellement edouard
philippe
avec quelques mots comment comment est
ce que vous qualifiez le bilan de notre
ancien premier ministre après plusieurs
années où où la france a traversé
vendant ses vents et marées écoutez il a
tenu bon avec je dirais des orientations
qui sont celles du printemps de la
république qui on le devine n était pas
forcément les fiennes mais c'est un
homme d'une grande loyauté
il a il a fait preuve je vous dis lui
lâché transcrire dans les faits avec je
vous dis également ses traits d'humour
que vous avez souligné
mais sa grande loyauté sa grande
simplicité mais c'était pas une
simplicité ou une loyauté fade c'est un
normand comme moi donc ce sont des gens
qui parlent peu qui agit je pense qu'on
en entendra amis vont parler gulli
on recrée ou son retour sur le père
d'andy nature en 2022
et pourquoi pas et pourquoi pas la
droite la droite est en recherche si je
puis dire de deux personnalités et nous
avons découvert un premier musique est
un homme efficace
je vous dit quelque chose il faut
recoudre les territoires comme dit le
président larcher et il faut rassembler
nos concitoyens il faut assurer je crois
que c'est un homme qui a su faire tout
cela alors que jeudi il a d'abord été
fidèle au président de la république et
on a bien vu au travers ça a été
d'ailleurs l'objet de notre discussion
mardi au sénat en aparté j'ai bien vu
qu'il y avait un clivage lors des
orientations de la convention citoyenne
sur le climat
on sentait que ce n'était pas entre guy
des murs est loin s'en faut sa tasse de
thé
je ne vous en dirais pas plus est l
objet de notre conversation
jean bizet revenant à jean castex un
petit peu inconnu du grand public comme
de droite élu local et bon connaisseur
de l'état qu'est ce qu'il attend pour la
rentrée quels sont les gros dossiers qui
l'attendent pour cette rentrée après
après cette épidémie due qu'aux vie de
19 ans très difficile difficule sur le
plan social
parce que la problématique dégager les
jaunes couve encore bookeen parce que
l'état de droit n'existe plus en france
on l'a vu avec les toutes les bagarres
qui hier dans les banlieues
je crois très sincèrement aussi que nous
allons avoir des plans de licenciements
multiples et variées quelle que soit la
dimension du plan de relance qui est une
dimension inégalée totalement inégal et
là on voit très bien si vous voulez que
la france a péniblement allant jusqu'à
40 milliards d'euros
si vous voulez pour lutter contre les
conséquences de cette pandémie sur le
plan social sur le plan économique
quand l'allemagne elle il ya consacré
140 milliards d'euros donc il va falloir
que le premier ministre ou au travers si
je puis dire de la politique européenne
parce que ça ne se résout plus haut
niveau des états nations et bien et
c'est d'éviter cette fragmentation du
marché unique et ajoutez à cela un
principe qui s'annonce très difficile
voire dur donc le premier ministre a un
énorme chantier à la fois je vous dis
social économique et si en plus au
niveau environnemental
eh bien on s'oriente vers de la
décroissance parce que ce soit
véritablement les orientations de la
convention citoyenne pour le poma je
suis très inquiet pour la rentrée
merci jean bizet pour cette analyse nos
politiques je rappelle que vous êtes
sénateur et l'air de la manche président
est de la commission des affaires
européennes du sénat
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain point en
actualité dans 30 minutes avec à magali
forestier restez avec nous sur arte
france
[Musique]
m
bertrand piccard vous vouliez prouvé que
l'on pouvait voyager au solaire et vous
avez fait le tour du monde
moi mon ambition c'est de montrer que
les technologies propres et les énergies
renouvelables peuvent faire des choses a
priori impossible sur la rime paul
c'était vraiment le laboratoire volant
qui montrait que non seulement on
pouvait s'alimenter au solaire non plus
on pouvait être extrêmement efficients
sur le plan de l'énergie par rapport aux
problèmes là du climat de